[Music]
smart cities is basically information
and communications technology applied to
traffic or Public Safety or Water and
Sewer technology can bring a lot of
solutions to the challenges of cities
faced and that gets us smart but you got
to take it another step when you define
traffic as automobiles buses bikes
pedestrians folks who have to use a
wheelchair to get around their city
project by project is improving the
quality of life for everybody by making
traffic light smarter that actually
monitor the traffic build up in each
direction in real-time and then turn
green the direction where the traffic
buildup is very high and then also
communicate with the subsequent traffic
light saying that I am sending traffic
your way we can actually coordinate a
patek flow across the city dynamically
making decisions every couple of seconds
you can actually monitor air pollution
and basically bring in policies and
solutions actually reduce pollution that
will be fewer automotive accidents
injuries and fatalities classic will
flow smoother so a mother taking her
child to school we will actually get
there on time
so we at CMU as academics one basically
creates this body of knowledge
technologies policies and solutions
which get deployed in real cities in
real metropolitan regions that almost
time basically becomes a bedrock on
which other cities of societies can
build upon by being a university that
wrestles with the real-world problems
brings its research and development
capabilities to bear on those problems
and partners with whether its cities or
corporations other countries we multiply
the total impact on a global population